Okay, so I'm standing here on Navy Pier in Chicago. And could I just ask you to describe the outfit you're wearing?
好的，我现在正站在芝加哥的海军码头。我能请你描述一下你身上穿的衣服吗？
Just a pair of slacks, a knit top to go with it.
只是一条休闲裤，搭配一件针织上衣。
And the color of the slacks?
那裤子是什么颜色的？
The slacks are white.
裤子是白色的。
White after Labor Day. There was a time this woman, Hazel, would not have dared wear white after Labor Day, she says. But that tradition of autumn is long dead, so long dead it's barely even worth commenting on. That's right. There's only one tradition anybody like Hazel still follows come September.
劳动节之后穿白色。曾几何时，这位名叫海泽尔的女士说，她绝不敢在劳动节之后穿白色。但那个秋季的传统早已过时，过时到几乎不值得一提。没错，对于像海泽尔这样的人来说，到了九月，只有一个传统还在遵循。
Oh, yeah, I go to clearance sales, especially at the end of the summer when they've got all the winter clothes out. And you're looking for all the goodies that's left over. Oh, you can't miss that.
哦，是的，我会去大甩卖，特别是在夏末，那时候他们会把所有冬装都拿出来。你在寻找剩下的好东西。哦，你绝对不能错过。
Gotten anything this year like that?
今年买到什么好东西了吗？
Yes, I did.
买到了。
You did?
真的吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
What'd you get?
你买了什么？
I got a beautiful pink sport jacket at Carson's. Oh, I got a nice bargain on it.
我在卡森百货买了一件漂亮的粉色运动夹克。哦，我买得特别划算。
Well, from WBEZ in Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And today on our program, we clear out the inventory for fall and pass those savings on to you. Over the last six months, we have commissioned on our program a number of stories, and found a number of stories, that we on the little radio staff love, but have not been able to figure out a way to fit into any of the actual shows we've put on the air for you. That's the problem of working with a theme every week.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目要清理库存，把这些优惠带给你们。在过去六个月里，我们委托并发现了一些故事，我们电台的工作人员都很喜欢，但一直没能想出办法把它们融入到我们播出的任何正式节目中。这就是每周围绕一个主题工作的问题所在。
And so we just thought, we love these stories. You will love them. Let's just put them together and get them on the air.
所以我们就想，我们喜欢这些故事，你们也会喜欢的。干脆把它们整合在一起播出吧。
In this hour, Act One. David Sedaris, In the Nude.
本期节目，第一幕：大卫·塞达里斯的《裸体》。
Act Two, Haiku at the Scrimmage Line. Stories from Scott Carrier, one of our favorite contributors.
第二幕：《混战中的俳句》。来自我们最喜欢的撰稿人之一斯科特·卡里尔的故事。
Act Three, Animal Lover. That's a piece of found writing.
第三幕：《爱动物的人》。这是一段发现的文字。
Act Four, Grandma and Easy.
第四幕：《祖母与伊兹》。
I know, by the way, that some of you may have heard promos saying that our show today was going to be about a hot dog stand. And our program about the hot dog stand was not ready for you. It was not up to our standards.
顺便说一下，我知道你们有些人可能听过预告，说我们今天的节目是关于热狗摊的。但我们关于热狗摊的节目还没有准备好，它没达到我们的标准。
And so we are bringing you the program that we had planned for next week, which is in good shape. It's tomorrow's stories today. Stay with us.
所以我们带来了原计划下周播出的节目，内容已经准备就绪。这是明天的故事，今天播。请继续收听。
Act one, In the Nude. So we're going to kick things off with this story from David Sedaris. David is a sometimes commentator on NPR's Morning Edition, a frequent contributor to This American Life, author of the book Barrel Fever. And he's working on a new book of stories called Naked. And for the title story in that collection, he decided to spend a week at a nudist colony.
第一幕，《裸体》。我们先从大卫·塞达里斯的这个故事开始。大卫是NPR《早间新闻》的特约评论员，《美国生活》的常客，也是《酒桶热》一书的作者。他正在创作一本名为《裸体》的新故事集。为了这本集子的同名故事，他决定在裸体主义者聚居区住上一周。
David is not somebody who likes being naked. As he's written, he doesn't even like walking around the house barefoot, much less nude. He doesn't sleep in the nude. And so this was his personal challenge to himself.
大卫不是一个喜欢裸体的人。正如他所写，他甚至不喜欢在家里光脚走来走去，更不用说裸体了。他睡觉也不裸睡。所以这对他是个人挑战。
During the summer, he read a portion of this story with his sister Amy at a club called KGB in New York City. And as you're going to hear, these are just anecdotes from a larger story. It's not a complete story. But it's really funny and interesting and fun to listen to.
夏天的时候，他在纽约市一家叫KGB的俱乐部和他妹妹艾米一起读了这个故事的一部分。正如你即将听到的，这只是一个更大故事中的轶事，并不是一个完整的故事。但它非常有趣，很有意思。
So before we start, a quick warning. There's no sex in this story. In fact, it's possibly the least sexy imaginable story. But there are references to specific body parts that might not be judged suitable for some children. So use your judgment.
在开始之前，先给个简短的警告。这个故事里没有性。事实上，这可能是你能想象到的最不性感的了。但其中提到了一些身体部位，可能不适合某些孩子。请自行斟酌。
It is disconcerting to talk to someone on the phone and know that they are naked. Every now and then, I might call a friend who says, "You caught me on the way to the shower," but that's different. The man at the nudist colony sounded as though he had been naked for years. Even his voice was tanned.
在电话里和人交谈，知道对方是裸体的，这让人感到不安。偶尔我会给朋友打电话，他说：“你抓到我正要去洗澡，”但那不一样。这个裸体主义者聚居区的人说话的声音听起来好像他已经裸体好多年了。连他的声音都晒成了古铜色。
"All right then. Have you ever visited us before? No? Well, you're in for a treat. I'd be happy to send you a brochure. Let me just get your information here."
“好吧。你以前来过我们这儿吗？没有？那你有福了。我很乐意寄给你一本手册。让我记一下你的资料。”
In this afternoon's mail, I received my brochure, along with a pamphlet that reads "Body acceptance is the idea. Nude recreation is the way. Bring your towels and suntan lotion and relax with us. You will experience a freedom of movement that cannot be felt with clothes, the freedom to be yourself."
今天下午的邮件里，我收到了手册，还有一本小册子，上面写着：“身体接纳是理念，裸体娱乐是方式。带上你的毛巾和防晒乳，和我们一起放松吧。你将体验到穿上衣服无法感受到的运动自由，做自己的自由。”
The brochure pictures a swimming pool, playground, sun deck, and the inevitable volleyball court, which leads me to wonder, what is it with these people and volleyball? The two go hand in hand. When I think nudist, I don't think penis. I think net.
手册上画着游泳池、游乐场、日光浴平台，还有不可避免的排球场，这让我很纳闷，这些人为什么这么执着于排球？这两者总是形影不离。当我想到裸体主义者时，我不会想到生殖器，我会想到球网。
Last night, I was in a foul mood and provoked Hugh into a fight, goading him until he fled the room, shouting, "You're a big, fat, hairy pig." Big is something I can live with. Fat is open to interpretation. But when coupled with hairy, it begins to form a mental picture which is brought into sharp focus when joined by the word "pig." A big, fat, hairy, pig. If I were nudist, Hugh's words wouldn't have hurt me, as I would've accepted myself for who I am.
昨晚，我心情很坏，激怒了休，不停地挑衅他，直到他跑出房间，喊道：“你这个又胖又多毛的大肥猪。”“大”是我能接受的，“胖”可以有多种解读，但当与“多毛”结合在一起时，它就开始形成一种心理画面，而当“猪”字加入时，这个画面就变得清晰了。一个又胖、又多毛的大肥猪。如果我是裸体主义者，休的话就不会伤到我，因为我会接纳我本来的样子。
I phoned the colony to make a reservation and spoke to the same fellow who had mailed me the brochure. This time, I could hear people in the background, splashing and yelling in merriment. The sound of them made me giddy, and I unbuttoned my slacks.
我打电话给聚居区预订，接电话的是那个寄手册给我的人。这一次，我能听到背景里有人在玩水、欢呼。他们的声音让我感到轻快，我解开了裤子的扣子。
The brochure had mentioned rental cabins, and I was wondering what it might cost to stay for a week. "You want a trailer for how long?" he asked. I re-fastened my pants. A trailer? I had pictured tree-shaded bungalows, paneled in knotty pine. That, to me, is the essence of the word "colony." This place, instead, was a nudist trailer park.
手册里提到了出租木屋，我想知道住一周要多少钱。“你要拖车住多久？”他问。我重新扣好裤子。拖车？我脑海里想的是那种绿树成荫、镶着松木板的平房。那才是“聚居区”这个词的精髓。而这个地方，实际上是个裸体主义者拖车营地。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
"We don't use the word 'colony' anymore, because it's too spooky. No, what we have are trailers. The smaller units run $30 a night. But if you want your own kitchen and bathroom, your only option is a double-wide, which will run you $10 more." He'd lost me way back. How was the word "colony" spooky, but not the word "trailer"?
“我们不再用‘聚居区’这个词了，因为听起来太诡异。不，我们有的是拖车。较小的单元一晚30美元。但如果你想要自己的厨房和浴室，你唯一的选择是双宽拖车，要多加10美元。”他刚才说的话已经把我搞晕了。怎么“聚居区”就诡异，而“拖车”就不诡异了？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Or even "nudist," for that matter. "I can let you have the front bedroom of the double-wide. That's not booked yet." Front bedroom suggested the evidence of a back bedroom, which I was told would be rented out separately. "You might have one roommate, or maybe it'll be a couple. Don't worry. You won't get lonely."
甚至“裸体主义者”也一样。“我可以把双宽拖车的前卧室留给你，还没被预订。”前卧室暗示了还有后卧室，我被告知后卧室会单独出租。“你可能会有一个室友，或者是一对夫妇。别担心，你不会感到寂寞的。”
A roommate at a nudist trailer park. The combination of these elements presented a staggering tableau, made all the more incomprehensible when I heard the man shoulder the phone and raise his voice to shout, "Mom! Hey, mom! Where's the weekly price list for the two-bedroom rental trailer?" This person was not only standing naked in broad daylight. He was doing it with his mother. I made my reservations and planned to arrive in one week.
在裸体拖车营地找个室友。这些元素的组合构成了一个惊人的场景，当我听到那个人离开电话提高嗓门喊：“妈！嘿，妈！两卧室出租拖车的每周价格表在哪？”时，这一切变得更加不可思议。这个人不仅在光天化日之下赤身裸体，而且还是和他母亲一起。我做了预订，计划一周后到达。
I called the park again today, and a woman answered. When asked if they provide sheets and pillows, she said--
我今天又给营地打了电话，是个女人接的。当被问到是否提供床单和枕头时，她说——
"Yes, but no towels. You'll have to bring your own towels, because we can't be doing that. Bedding yes, towels no."
“有的，但不提供毛巾。你得自带毛巾，因为我们做不到那样。床上用品可以，毛巾不行。”
I asked if the trailer's kitchen was equipped. And she replied--
我问拖车的厨房设备是否齐全。她回答——
"Eh, kind of."
“嗯，算是吧。”
Seeing as I would be there for a week, I was hoping she might elaborate.
既然我要在那儿住一周，我希望她能说得详细点。
"Well, it kind of has some things and not some others."
“嗯，它有一样没一样的。”
"Does it kind of have a stove and refrigerator?"
“它有炉子和冰箱吗？”
"Oh, sure. There's a sink up there and probably some pans and so forth, but definitely no towels. You'll have to pack your own, because we can't be running back and forth like that. We haven't got the time for that kind of thing."
“哦，当然。上面有个水槽，可能还有些锅碗瓢盆什么的，但绝对没有毛巾。你必须打包自己的，因为我们不能跑来跑去折腾那个。我们没时间处理那种事情。”
I told her I understood--
我告诉她我明白了——
"A lot of folks think we keep a nice, fluffy stack of towels up by the pool for their own private use, but we don't do that. Not here, we don't. Not anymore."
“很多人以为我们在泳池边放了一叠又软又蓬松的毛巾供他们私用，但我们不那样做。这儿不那样。不再那样了。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
"Towels are personal things, and you'll have to bring your own."
“毛巾是私人物品，你必须自带。”
I truly had--
我真的——
"So sometimes, a person might come in for a day and leave their towel behind by accident. But we put that towel in the lost and found box, in case they come back looking for it. You can't use those towels, because they're not clean, and they don't belong to you.
“所以有时候，有人可能会来住一天，不小心把毛巾丢下。但我们把毛巾放进失物招领箱，万一他们回来找。你不能用那些毛巾，因为它们不干净，而且不属于你。
That somebody might come back one day to claim that towel. And it wouldn't do for them to walk in and find you using it without their permission. It wouldn't be right.
万一有人回来认领那条毛巾呢？如果你未经许可就在用它，这可不行。这不合适。
Now if it was lotion, I might say, 'Oh go ahead. I'll do your back.' But it's not lotion. No, you'll have to bring your own."
如果那是乳液，我可能会说，‘噢，没关系。我帮你抹背。’但那不是乳液。不，你得自带。”
I underlined the word towels on my list of things to pack and placed question marks beside everything else. I arrived early on this cold and wet afternoon, the cab driver dumping me off in front of the clubhouse before squealing away. Something about the place seemed to make him nervous, and he couldn't wait to get back into town. I collected my bag and entered a low, clapboard building where five fully dressed senior citizens sat hugging themselves against the cold and watching the local news on a color television bolted to a high shelf. On the screen, a weatherman was pointing to a map studded with frowning clowns-- clouds.
我在打包清单上的“毛巾”一词下划了线，并在其他所有东西旁边打上了问号。我在这寒冷潮湿的下午早早抵达，出租车司机把我扔在会所门前就尖叫着开走了。这个地方好像让他很紧张，他迫不及待地想回到镇上。我收起包，走进一座低矮的木板建筑，那里有五个衣着完整的退休老人蜷缩着身体抵御寒冷，盯着高架上那台彩色电视机看当地新闻。屏幕上，气象员正指着一张布满皱眉小丑——不，是云朵的地图。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
On the screen, a weatherman was pointing to a map studded with frowning suns, his arms positioned as if he were drawing a heavy curtain. The inhabitants of the room leaned forward in their chairs, biting the ridges of their clenched fists and groaning when confronted with the words "cold front." They booed the weatherman. They cursed him, and then they pounded upon the table tops, much like prisoners unhappy with their food.
屏幕上，气象员指着一张布满皱眉太阳的地图，他张开双臂，仿佛在拉开厚重的窗帘。房间里的人身体前倾，紧咬着攥紧的拳头，当听到“冷锋”这个词时，他们发出呻吟。他们向气象员喝倒彩，咒骂他，然后像对食物不满的囚犯一样捶打桌面。
The room was filled with the rhythmic thuds of protest as I sat down my suitcase and approached the front desk. "He did this," a man said, pointing his crooked finger in my direction. "Brought this nastiness with him down from the lakes."
房间里充满了这种有节奏的抗议声，我放下手提箱走向前台。“是他干的，”一个男人指着我这边说，“把这晦气从湖区带了下来。”
"You from the lakes?"
“你是从湖区来的吗？”
--the woman behind the counter asked. The corners of her mouth hung so low, they grazed the line of her jaw. She narrowed her eyes upon my suitcase, almost suspecting to find it blustering across the floor, packed as it was with storm clouds and unseasonable winds.
柜台后的女人问道。她的嘴角低垂，几乎触及下颚线。她眯起眼睛盯着我的手提箱，好像怀疑它会带着风暴云和反季节大风在地上呼啸。
"I don't know anything about any lakes." There was a rising panic in my voice. "It was hot and sunny when I left this morning. Really, it was. It turned cold around Scranton, but I didn't even get off the bus. It's the truth. You can ask the driver." It was ridiculous to stand before a group of strangers, denying my responsibility for the weather. But at the moment, the charges seemed entirely plausible.
“我不知道什么湖区。”我声音里带着上升的恐惧，“我早上离开时天气又热又晴朗。真的。到了斯克兰顿天气变冷了，但我根本没下车。这是事实。你可以问司机。”站在一群陌生人面前否认自己对天气的责任是很荒唐的，但在那一刻，这些指控看起来完全说得通。
"Well, it's supposed to clear up by tomorrow afternoon. But if it doesn't, I'll know where to find you. Right there, that's your trailer there, with the orange trim."
“好吧，天气预报说明天下午会转晴。但如果不转晴，我就知道去哪找你了。就是那儿，你的拖车在那，带橙色饰边的那个。”
"You mean, the one with the rust-colored band?"
“你是说那个带铁锈色带子的？”
"You call it rust. I say it's orange. But you get the idea. It's the one with the picnic table in the front yard. Front bedroom, that's you.
“你管它叫铁锈，我管它叫橙色。但你明白我的意思了。就是前院带野餐桌的那辆。前卧室，那是你的。”
I painted it myself, and the can said burnt orange. If it had said rust, I never would have bought it. It only looks rusty under those clouds you brought. Sunny day comes, and you'll see it's orange. I'm sorry I can't just rush out there and repaint it to meet your needs, your standards. But I've got other things to do."
“我自己漆的，漆罐上写的是焦橙色。如果上面写的是铁锈色，我绝对不会买。它只有在你带来的云朵下看起来才像锈色。晴天一出来，你就会发现它是橙色的。很抱歉我不能赶过去为了你的需要、你的标准重新漆一遍。但我还有别的事要做。”
I asked where I might find a key to my trailer and heard a round of muffled laughter coming from the far corners of the room.
我问哪里能拿到拖车钥匙，听到房间角落里传来一阵压抑的笑声。
"Shhhh. We don't believe in locked doors. Not here we don't, not anymore. Maybe where you come from, people barricade themselves behind closed doors. But here, we have no reason. We don't lock our doors, because we have nothing to hide."
“嘘。我们不相信锁门。我们这儿不锁，不再锁了。也许在你来的地方，人们躲在紧闭的门后。但在这里，我们没有理由。我们不锁门，因为我们没什么可隐瞒的。”
I walked up the gravel lane to my trailer, which had been sprayed with so much insecticide it curled the hairs in my nose. Raisin-sized flies lay gasping on the countertops, their upturned legs signing the words--
我沿着碎石路走到我的拖车前，拖车被喷了太多杀虫剂，熏得我鼻毛都卷了。葡萄大小的苍蝇倒在台面上喘着气，它们翻转的腿签写着——
"Get out of here fast while you still have a chance. Ugh."
“趁还有机会快逃走。呃。”
I set down my suitcase and fled, trotting past the clubhouse to the soggy volleyball court. The same pool I had seen in the brochure was now covered by a tarp, as was the hot tub. Even the flag was at half mast.
我放下手提箱逃了出去，小跑着经过会所来到潮湿的排球场。我在手册里看到的同一个游泳池现在盖上了防水布，热浴盆也是。甚至连旗帜都降了一半。
I woke this morning to a fog so thick I couldn't see the picnic table in my front yard. From the sky to the ground, everything was the exact same shade of gray. It was cold, too, maybe in the low 50s.
今天早上醒来时，大雾浓得让我看不见前院的野餐桌。从天空到地面，全是一模一样的灰色。天气也冷，大概在50多度左右。
Late last night, my water shut off. And it didn't kick in again until 8 o'clock this morning. I got dressed and went to the clubhouse, where I spoke to the woman at the front desk, who wore a turtleneck sweatshirt and drank cocoa from a mug she held with both hands.
昨晚晚些时候，我这边停水了。直到今天早上8点才恢复。我穿好衣服去了会所，和柜台后的女人说了话，她穿着高领运动衫，双手捧着马克杯喝可可。
"If you're here about the water, there's nothing I can do. We operate on wells, and sometimes they leak. It's a troublesome thing, a leaky well. So what we do, we shut down the pump around bedtime and turn it back on first thing in the morning.
“如果你是为停水来的，我爱莫能助。我们靠水井供水，有时水井会漏。漏水井是个麻烦事。所以我们通常在睡觉时关掉水泵，早上第一时间再打开。”
Today, we got a late start. Most times, it's back on by 7:00, but Russell, handyman, didn't get back from his yoga class until close to 8 o'clock, on account of he threw out his shoulder doing some damn thing, whatever those people do tying themselves in knots in the presence of some yogi wearing a turban or god knows what, a loincloth-- I don't like to think about it while I'm drinking my cocoa."
“今天我们起晚了。大多数时候，7点就恢复了，但维修工拉塞尔，因为上瑜伽课一直到近8点才回来，因为他在某些瑜伽修行者——或者天知道什么人，穿着缠腰布——面前做些该死的动作把肩膀扭了。喝可可的时候我可不想想这个。”
She reached beneath the counter and pulled out two marshmallows, which she stuffed into her mug.
她伸手从柜台下拿出两块棉花糖，塞进杯子里。
"If the water's out in your orange trailer, you can always use the bathroom in the clubhouse. Door's always open."
“如果你的橙色拖车停水了，你随时可以使用会所的浴室。门总是开着的。”
The fog burned off slowly. By 6 o'clock, it was clear and sunny. And I looked out my window to see a naked couple strutting across the grounds with a pair of tennis racquets. The man wore his hair long in the back and carried himself as if he were dressed in a fine suit, his stride confident and purposeful, while the woman trotted behind him wearing a sun visor, knee socks, and sneakers.
雾气慢慢散去。到了6点，天气晴朗了。我从窗户往外看，看到一对裸体夫妇挥舞着网球拍大摇大摆地穿过场地。那个男人后脑勺留着长发，走起路来好像穿着昂贵的西装，步伐自信且坚定，而那个女人戴着遮阳帽、穿着膝盖袜和运动鞋跟在他后面小跑。
These were the first active nudists I had seen. And I put on my pants and followed them, taking a seat beside the pavilion and pretending to read a book. The man had an ample stomach and a broad, dimpled ass which jiggled and swayed as he leapt about the court, attempting to return his partner's serves. They played for maybe five minutes before the man placed his hands on his knees, released a mouthful of bile onto the grass, and called it quits. They left the court, and I followed them into the clubhouse, where the man stepped into the bathroom, and the woman spoke to our hostess, who stood behind the counter, sorting change.
这是我见过的第一批活跃的裸体主义者。我穿上裤子跟在他们后面，坐在凉亭旁边假装看书。男人有个大肚子和宽阔、有酒窝的屁股，他在场地上跳来跳去试图回击搭档的发球时，屁股不停地抖动摆动。他们打了大概五分钟，男人就把手放在膝盖上，向草地上吐了一口胆汁，宣布不打了。他们离开了球场，我跟着他们走进会所，男人进了浴室，女人则与我们的女主人说话，女主人正站在柜台后整理零钱。
"Oh, looks like you brought some nice weather with you. Tennis player, are you? Oh, that court doesn't get much use during the week. But come Saturday, you'll have lots of folks to play with, though none of them are as good as you.
“噢，看来你带来了一些好天气。你是网球运动员吧？噢，那个球场平时用的人不多。但到了周六，会有很多人跟你打，虽然他们没你打得那么好。”
I saw you through the window there. Haven't had a player like you in a long while. Why, you're a regular what's-her-name, the girl who got stabbed back a few years ago. Yeah, yeah. You're good. I hope you and your husband will be staying for a while, maybe come up to my place for supper and a game of cards."
“我从窗户那儿看见你了。好久没来过你这样的选手了。怎么，你简直就是那个谁，那个几年前被刺伤的女孩。没错，没错。你打得真好。我希望你和你丈夫能多住一段时间，也许可以来我这吃晚饭玩牌。”
The women had always been so cold to me but fell over herself making sure the married couple found everything to their liking. I heard the toilet flush, and the man re-entered the room with a bright red ring around his ass. Here, I thought, was a real nudist. And I stared at him as though he had just stepped down from a flying saucer. There was a tuft of toilet paper, just slight, clinging to his bottom. And when his wife pointed it out, he ran his hand along his crack and casually shrugged, as though it were nothing more significant than a dab of mayonnaise on his lips.
那个女人对我一直很冷淡，但现在却殷勤地确保这对已婚夫妇对一切都感到满意。我听到厕所冲水声，男人重新走进房间，屁股周围有一圈鲜红的痕迹。我想，这才是真正的裸体主义者。我盯着他，就像他刚从飞碟上走下来一样。有一小片卫生纸挂在他的屁股上。当他妻子指出这一点时，他顺着沟壑摸了一下，随随便便耸了耸肩，就好像那不过是嘴边沾了一点蛋黄酱而已。
"Oh, yeah. The two of you should join us some night for nude bowling. Yeah, we rent out whole place and have ourself a tournament. Oh, I can't race around a tennis court the way you can, but hand me a bowling ball, and I'll mop the floor with you. Hold on just a moment, will you? We've got ourselves a complainer standing in the back of the room. Well, what do you want?"
“噢，是的。你们俩哪天应该加入我们参加裸体保龄球赛。是的，我们租下整个场地举行锦标赛。噢，我没法像你一样在球场上跑来跑去，但只要把保龄球递给我，我就能把你杀得片甲不留。稍微等一下好吗？后面有个爱抱怨的人。好吧，你想要什么？”
Looking out my bedroom window, I could see the clubhouse and its parking area. Earlier today, I watched as a large trailer pulled up, marked with Maryland plates and led by a four-door late-model car. This was someone arriving to park their trailer and stay for the summer.
从卧室窗户望去，我可以看到会所和停车场。今天早些时候，我看到一辆挂着马里兰州车牌、由新款四门车牵引的大型拖车开了进来。这是有人来停放拖车准备过夏天。
The car door opened, and a man stepped out, completely naked. He'd been driving like that on the highway. I guess he just couldn't wait.
车门打开，一个男人完全裸体走了出来。他在高速公路上竟然一直这样开车。我猜他实在等不及了。
I spoke to a woman in the sauna who said--
我跟桑拿房里的一个女人说了话，她说——
"Oh, you should've been here for last year's pudding toss."
“噢，你应该来看看去年的布丁投掷。”
"I beg your pardon?" Pudding toss, I thought it must be some expression like "sock hop." "Pudding isn't conducive to being tossed, is it?"
“请原谅？”布丁投掷，我想这一定是什么像“袜子舞会”之类的表达。“布丁不适合投掷吧？”
"Oh, no, you can toss it. You just can't catch it."
“噢，不，你可以扔。只是接不到。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
"Yeah, what we do is we make it up in five-gallon tubs and carry it out in the field, where we have a chocolate team against the vanillas. Then we just start pitching it at one another. And oh, it's a good time. Some good times, yeah. We can't do it this year. It attracted too many bees and files, which pretty much occupied the field for the next few months. But it was fun. I should let it go.
“是的，我们是在五加仑的大桶里搅拌好，搬到地里，巧克力队对阵香草队。然后我们就开始互相扔。哦，那真好玩。真是好时光。今年我们不能搞了。招来了太多的蜜蜂和苍蝇，之后几个月几乎占领了那片地。但真好玩。我该放下了。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This is Sunday, and looking out my window, I've noticed a lot of people come to the nudist park right after church. I watch as they stand beside their cars, removing their sober suits and stripping off their dresses. One of today's guests was a Presbyterian minister, a plump, freckle-faced man with Daffy Duck tattooed on his ass.
今天是周日，从窗户往外看，我注意到很多人在教堂礼拜后会立刻来到裸体主义者营地。我看着他们站在车旁，脱下庄重的西装，褪去连衣裙。今天的一位客人是长老会牧师，一个长着雀斑的胖子，屁股上纹着达菲鸭。
I've seen plenty of tattoos, but none I've wanted to kick quite like that duck. He wore it with a swagger, calling attention to a body part the Lord had clearly not blessed with muscle tone or unblemished skin. The duck's beak was distended, and he appeared to be picking at a rash of strawberries.
我看过很多纹身，但没见过比那只鸭子更想让人踢一脚的了。他带着一种傲慢炫耀着它，引起人们对上帝显然没有赐予肌肉张力或无瑕皮肤的身体部位的注意。那只鸭子的喙是扭曲的，看起来好像在啄食一阵草莓皮疹。
There are quite a few new faces today. A black man arrived in the company of two enormous white women, whose bodies were dual masses of rolling, dimpled flesh. Fat spilled over their knees, and their stomachs fell like heavy sacks of bird feed. Legs like tree trunks led straight into sandals, with no mention of ankle or discernible calf.
今天有不少新面孔。一个黑人男人在两个巨大的白人妇女的陪伴下到来，她们的身体是两团滚动着、带有酒窝的肉。脂肪从膝盖上溢出，肚子像沉重的鸟饲料袋一样下垂。像树干一样的腿直接延伸到凉鞋里，看不到脚踝或明显的腿肚子。
"Jesus, who's that colored guy, and how come he's got two women? Jesus, you reckon he's one of those pimps that come down here from Syracuse?"
“天哪，那个黑人是谁，他怎么有两个女人？天哪，你觉得他是从雪城来的那些皮条客吗？”
This was the only black person I'd seen all week. And by the time he left, it had been decided that--
这是我一周来见到的唯一一个黑人。等他走的时候，大家都已经断定——
"What he did was kidnap those girls. He's going to try to sell them as white slaves once he crosses the border into Canada, where the men will do anything to get their hands on a white woman."
“他干的是绑架了那些女孩。他打算等越过边界进入加拿大后，把她们当作白人奴隶卖掉，那里的男人为了得到一个白人女人什么都干得出来。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I've taken to joining the group of seniors who gather naked each evening to watch Wheel of Fortune on the clubhouse TV.
我开始加入每晚赤身裸体聚在会所电视机前看《命运之轮》的老人行列。
"Ask for an E. Oh, I meant a C. Oh, she's smart, that one."
“选一个E。噢，我是指C。噢，她真聪明，那个女孩。”
It's an odd sensation, watching television this way. Because they are dressed, the people on TV seem even more remote than usual.
这种看电视的方式感觉很奇怪。因为电视里的人穿着衣服，他们看起来比平时更加遥远。
"Oh, I wish this show was naked. It would be so much better that way, don't you think? They could take the money they spent on wardrobe and make the prizes bigger. I'd play the nude version and make enough money to build a big lake with lots of boats and tuna towers."
“噢，我真希望这节目是裸体的。那样会好得多，你不觉得吗？他们可以把花在服装上的钱省下来，让奖品变得更丰厚。我要玩那个裸体版本，赚够钱盖一个带有很多船和金枪鱼塔的大湖。”
I liked the idea of that, filming two separate versions of any given program, one clothed and one naked. "Do I have to?" Peter Jennings would ask.
我喜欢这个主意，为任何给定的节目拍摄两个独立的版本，一个穿衣版，一个裸体版。“我非得这么做吗？”彼得·詹宁斯会问。
Due to the pleasant weather, the tarp has been taken off the swimming pool, which is surround it by comfortable reclining chairs, several of them positioned beneath a sign reading Handicapped Parking. It is a posted rule that you have to be naked inside the pool area. And I was just getting used to the idea when I was approached by a man named Dusty, who had clothes-pinned a piece of shirt cardboard to the brim of his sun visor in order to extend its shading capacities.
由于天气不错，游泳池上的防水布被取下了。周围摆满了舒适的躺椅，其中几张位于一块写着“残疾人停车位”的牌子下面。规定在泳池区内必须裸体。我刚习惯这个想法时，一个叫达斯蒂的男人走近我，他用衣夹把一块衬衫纸板夹在遮阳帽的帽檐上，以扩大遮阳范围。
The man was doubled over, stopped with osteoporosis, his back and shoulders burnished like fine Italian leather, and his belly white from lack of sun. He wore his thick, gray hair cut close to his head and favored mirrored sunglasses, which reflected the sight of my pale, fidgety nakedness. I asked him a question about the hot tub. And two hours later, he'd worked the subject around to the zoning ordinances of his hometown.
那个男人因骨质疏松而弯腰驼背，他的背部和肩膀被晒得像上好的意大利皮革，肚子却因为缺乏阳光而苍白。他留着厚厚的灰白短发，戴着反光墨镜，映出了我苍白、坐立不安的裸体。我问了他一个关于热浴盆的问题。两个小时后，他把话题扯到了他家乡的分区条例上。
"I don't think that legally, you're allowed to build a grocery store in my neighborhood, because it's not zoned for that. Oh, there used to be a little mom and pop operation where you could buy bread and soda and so forth, but that's been closed down and turned into a little church for the snake handlers. You might could put up an apartment building in my area, but first you'd have to check with the city council, because I'm not sure it's zoned for that. How big of a place did you want to put up?"
“我不认为在法律上你可以在我家附近盖杂货店，因为它没有被规划为那样。噢，过去曾有一家小夫妻店，你可以买面包、汽水什么的，但那已经倒闭了，变成了一个玩蛇教派的小教堂。你也许能在我们那盖栋公寓楼，但首先你得去问市议会，因为我不确定它是否被规划为那样。你想盖多大的地方？”
Had I mistakenly introduced myself as a real estate speculator? What was all this talk about building permits and zoning ordinances? "Course, down in the city, I guess you could build yourself an eight-story concrete beehive, just so long as you had the moolah to pay everybody off. That's the way it goes down where you come from, anything for a dollar. Then you come up here with your blueprints and steam shovels, thinking we're all a bunch of stupid hicks."
难道我误把自己介绍成房地产投机商了吗？这些关于建筑许可证和分区条例的谈话是怎么回事？“当然，在城里，我想你可以给自己盖个八层高的混凝土蜂巢，只要你有钱买通所有人。这就是你们那里办事的方式，为了钱什么都干。然后你带着蓝图和蒸汽铲来到这里，认为我们都是一群愚蠢的乡巴佬。”
He mugged, widening his face into a loopy, exaggerated grin, and running the tip of his tongue around the track of his lips. "We just a group of bumpkins, are we?" His attitude was both playful and hostile, and was shared by many of the people I met during my stay. Something about New York seemed to rub people the wrong way. This was a family campground. And New York was, to many of them, the place where wholesome families are shot down for sport.
他扮了个鬼脸，把脸扭曲成一种滑稽、夸张的笑容，舌尖滑过嘴唇。“我们只是群乡下人，是吧？”他的态度既好玩又有敌意，我住在这里期间遇到的很多人都有这种态度。纽约的某些东西似乎让人们感到不快。这是一个家庭露营地。而纽约，对他们许多人来说，是那种健全家庭为了运动而被射杀的地方。
Tonight was a scheduled hobo slumgullion, and we were instructed to bring our canned vegetables to the pavilion by noon. I took the only canned good in my pantry and carried it down the hill, where I found two naked women wearing chef's hats and stirring a cauldron of ground beef and water.
今晚计划举办一场流浪汉炖菜晚会，我们被要求在中午前把罐装蔬菜带到凉亭。我拿出储藏室里唯一的罐头，带下山去，发现两个戴着厨师帽的裸体女人正在搅拌一锅碎牛肉和水。
"Just pray nobody brings any more corn. We got it coming out of our goddamned [BLEEP] holes."
“只求别再有人带玉米了。我们已经快从该死的[哔]洞里冒出玉米来了。”
I set down my can of corn and asked what they meant by hobo slumgullion.
我放下那罐玉米，问她们所说的“流浪汉炖菜”是什么意思。
"Jesus, it's a stew. This here is the base. And we add whatever people bring, which in your case, Jesus, I don't even have to look, corn. Come 5 o'clock, we'll all gather together and dress like hobos and eat out of tin cans. It's fun. You'll see."
“天哪，就是炖菜。这就是底料。我们加入人们带来的任何东西，你的情况，天哪，我都不用看，是玉米。到了5点，我们都会聚集在一起，穿得像流浪汉一样，从铁皮罐头里吃。这很有趣。你会看到的。”
It struck me as an odd choice for a theme party. You hardly ever hear the word "hobo" anymore. To me, it always carried a romantic connotation. But now, it's been replaced by the word "homeless."
我觉得这是一场主题派对的奇怪选择。现在你几乎听不到“流浪汉”这个词了。对我来说，它总是带有浪漫色彩。但现在，它已经被“无家可归者”这个词取代了。
"Fine, then. Dress like a homeless person. But be here by 5 o'clock, because this [BLEEP]'s going to go fast."
“行吧，行吧。穿得像个无家可归的人。但5点前一定要到这里，因为这玩意儿[哔]很快就会被吃光的。”
I returned to the pavilion at the scheduled time, where 50 people sat eating out of cans. One man had smeared some charcoal on his cheeks. He wore a tie against this bare chest and carried a stick, onto which he had fastened a plastic grocery bag. Everyone else was naked, so he won the prize.
我在预定时间回到凉亭，50个人正坐在那儿吃罐头。一个男人在脸颊上抹了些木炭。他在这赤裸的胸膛前系了条领带，拿着根棍子，上面绑着个塑料杂货袋。其他人都赤身裸体，所以他赢得了奖品。
David Sedaris is the author of the book Barrel Fever . This was an excerpt from a story in his upcoming book, Naked. Amy Sedaris appears on stage and television.
大卫·塞达里斯是《酒桶热》一书的作者。这是他即将出版的书《裸体》中一个故事的节选。艾米·塞达里斯活跃在舞台和电视上。
Act Two. Well, this is our fall clearance program. And the next item that we are pulling off the shelves for you is this set of stories by Scott Carrier. He's a writer and radio producer living in Salt Lake City.
第二幕。好吧，这是我们的秋季清理计划。我们要为你们从货架上拿出的下一个项目是斯科特·卡里尔的这些故事。他是住在盐湖城的作家和广播制作人。
And he sent us these little stories that are really hard to classify. They're vignettes with this-- they have this very special and particular attitude to them. He records them sitting in his backyard in Salt Lake City.
他寄给我们的这些小故事真的很难分类。它们是些短片，带有一种非常特殊、独特的态度。他在盐湖城的后院录制了这些故事。
Because they're so anecdotal, it's actually been hard to figure out how to program them into one of our regular shows. But the radio staff and I, we love these very much and thought you would find them interesting. And it's the perfect time to play them.
因为它们太像轶事，所以实际上很难把它们编排进我们的常规节目中。但我和电台同事非常喜欢它们，觉得你们也会觉得很有意思。现在正是播放它们的绝佳时机。
It was between plays. The coach was talking to the offense in the huddle, drawing on his sketch board, reprimanding somebody for screwing up the last play. We were standing around, waiting. We were the defense, and we had no coach. We had three or four formations we'd run, but we'd never made a call until the last minute.
那是在两次进攻之间。教练在人群中对进攻组说话，在速写板上画着，斥责某人搞砸了上一次进攻。我们在旁边等着。我们是防守组，没有教练。我们有三四种阵型，但不到最后一刻绝不喊阵型。
I remember, because I made the calls. I was the monster man, the free safety, the captain of the defense. And I'd often call one formation as the offense broke huddle, and then stand back and wait until everyone was set, the quarterback going through his count, and then call another formation, just so everything would change shape right before the ball was snapped.
我记得，因为喊阵型的是我。我是怪兽人，自由安全卫，防守组队长。当进攻组散开时，我经常喊出一种阵型，然后站回后面，等大家都准备好，四分卫开始计数，我再喊出另一种阵型，这样一切都会在球被发出的瞬间改变阵型。
This added the elements of surprise and chaos to our attack. It made the offense respect and fear us. And often, their plays crumbled under the disorder we caused. I realize now I must have learned this strategy from my mother, who was at that time going crazy from a painful divorce.
这给我们的进攻增加了惊讶和混乱的元素。它让进攻组尊重并害怕我们。而且由于我们造成的混乱，他们的进攻经常崩溃。我现在意识到，我一定是从我母亲那里学到了这个策略，她在当时正因为一场痛苦的离婚而几近疯狂。
But there was this day, this practice I was talking about before, when the coach was in the offensive huddle. The sun was going down, and the practice was coasting to an end. We, the Highland Mighty Mite defense, were standing around quietly, minds empty, like 12-year-old desperadoes, waiting for a train. I was standing there, spacing out with everyone else.
但有一天，就是我刚才说的训练，教练在进攻组的人群里。夕阳西下，训练正进入尾声。我们，高地小强队防守组，正安静地站在那儿，头脑一片空白，就像一群等着火车的12岁亡命之徒。我站在那儿，和大家一起放空。
And then, I had this new feeling. I was conscious of being inside a shell, my by helmet and shoulder pads, looking out at the world, like my uniform and even my body were just protective packaging. I felt weightless. I was in love with the air, the smell of the grass, the warm light and the cottonwood trees at the edge of the field.
然后，我产生了一种新的感觉。我意识到自己身处一个外壳里，我的头盔和护肩，看着外面的世界，就像我的制服，甚至我的身体都只是保护性包装。我觉得身体很轻。我爱上了空气、草地的味道、温暖的阳光和球场边上的棉白杨树。
I remember looking out at Bruce Seymour, our big defensive end who had already reached puberty. He had his helmet tipped up, and his hair was all sweaty. And he was gnawing on his mouthpiece. He turned and looked at me.
我记得看向布鲁斯·西摩，我们那个已经进入青春期的大块头防守端锋。他把头盔推了上去，头发全是汗，正嚼着护齿。他转过头看着我。
And I wanted to say to him, "Do you feel it?" But I didn't know what "it" was. I didn't know how to explain what I was feeling.
我本来想对他说：“你感觉到了吗？”但我不知道“它”是什么。我不知道怎么解释我的感觉。
I called a huddle and said, "We're going to do something different this time. We'll line up in a regular 6-3 formation. But as they get set, I'm going to say a haiku. And I want you guys to start moving around. Dance around. Stand on your head. Do whatever you want. We'll kill them."
我喊了一个阵型说：“这次我们要玩点不一样的。我们要排成常规的6-3阵型。但在他们准备好时，我要背诵一段俳句。我要你们开始四处走动。跳舞。倒立。做你们想做的任何事。我们要干掉他们。”
The offense came out of their huddle, and we went into a 6-3. And just as the quarterback started his count, I yelled, "The wind brings dry leaves, enough to build a fire." And my defense stood up and looked at each other, and then looked at me, and didn't do anything.
进攻组从人群中出来，我们排成了6-3。就在四分卫开始计数时，我大喊：“风带来枯叶，足以燃起火。”我的防守组成员站起来互相对视，然后看着我，什么也没做。
It was so weird that the offense stood up, too. And then the coach blew his whistle and yelled, "What's going on? What's the problem?" Nobody spoke. He looked at me and said, "Carrier, what are you doing?"
太诡异了，进攻组也站了起来。然后教练吹响哨子大喊：“怎么回事？出什么问题了？”没人说话。他看着我说：“卡里尔，你在干什么？”
I said, "We're running a haiku." He said, "A what?" "A haiku," I said. "We learned it today in school. 'The wind brings dry leaves, enough to build a fire.'"
我说：“我们在玩俳句。”他说：“什么俳句？”“俳句，”我说，“我们今天在学校学的。‘风带来枯叶，足以燃起火。’”
He said, "Oh, right. Uh, a haiku. Just run a 6-3, OK?" So we ran a 6-3. And I don't remember what happened after that.
他说：“哦，对了。呃，俳句。还是跑6-3，好吗？”于是我们跑了6-3。我不记得之后发生了什么。
They've come down from the mountain, and they're not talking to each other. In the pole tent in base camp, below Alpamayo, the water is boiling for dinner. I'm making noodle soup and coca tea, as this is all the food we have left. Jenkins, Wyatt, and Mitsunaga are reading. My brother wants me to teach him some Spanish.
他们从山上下来，谁也不理谁。在阿尔帕马约山下的大本营帐篷里，晚饭的水在沸腾。我在做面条汤和古柯茶，这是我们剩下的所有食物。詹金斯、怀亚特和光永正在读书。我弟弟想让我教他西班牙语。
"Huesos del condor, los quiero huesos del condor." I'm telling him "bones of the condor," trying to make it simple. "Donde esta?" Over there is "A ya," usually with a hand signal. "En las montanas," up in the mountains, "a selva," the jungle, "oriental." He's paying attention, repeating, trying to memorize.
“Huesos del condor, los quiero huesos del condor。”我告诉他这是“秃鹰的骨头”，想把它简单化。“Donde esta？”那边是“A ya”，通常带个手势。“En las montanas，”在山上，“a selva，”丛林，“oriental。”他很专心，重复着，试图记住。
The've come down from the mountain, and they didn't get to the top. For two days, they tried the northwest ridge, and then spent the third day out on the north face, where Mitsunaga fell 50 feet, cartwheeling down a [UNINTELLIGIBLE], and Jenkins held him without a [? belay. ?] It was very steep on snow, rock, and ice. They were all scared and decided to bivouac in a snow cave.
他们从山上下来了，没能登顶。有两天他们尝试西北脊，第三天花在北壁上，光永在那里摔了50英尺，像翻筋斗一样滚下，詹金斯在没有保护的情况下抓住他。那里的雪、岩石和冰非常陡峭。他们都很害怕，决定在雪洞里露宿。
That evening, my brother watched a condor ride a thermal up the face of the mountain. He was looking down on it for 5,000 vertical feet. And when it was at the same level, they looked each other in the eye. Then we watched it from below as it went up another 1,000 feet and flew off over the top of the mountain.
那天晚上，我弟弟看着一只秃鹰乘着上升气流飞上山坡。他在5000英尺的高处俯瞰它。当它处于同一高度时，他们对视了一眼。然后我们在下面看着它又飞高了1000英尺，飞过了山顶。
The next morning, they decided to come back to base camp to get some more food. But there is no more food in base camp. And they're so hungry and mean-spirited, they think I ate everything. But really, they took the good stuff, the sardines, the sugar, and the butter, and ate it while they were climbing.
第二天早上，他们决定回到大本营拿点吃的。但大本营没吃的了。他们又饿又刻薄，以为是我把一切都吃了。但实际上，好东西——沙丁鱼、糖、黄油——都被他们在攀登时吃光了。
To get even, I tell them the story of the best meal I've ever had. I was hitchhiking through Montreal, coming from Alaska, going to Miami. And this woman driving a Mercedes picked me up and asked me if she could cook dinner for me. She said her husband was on call at the hospital, and she didn't like to eat alone. She was in her late 40s or early 50s, with the face of a falcon, quick, delicate eyes. She had a hypnotic voice, a Scandinavian accent, and her left hand had a knife scar running sideways across all her fingers.
为了报复，我给他们讲了我吃过的最好的一顿饭。我在蒙特利尔搭便车，从阿拉斯加来，要去迈阿密。一个开奔驰的女人载了我，问我能不能给我做顿饭。她说她丈夫在医院值班，她不喜欢独自吃饭。她40多岁或50岁出头，长着一张隼脸，眼神敏锐细腻。她有迷人的声音，带着斯堪的纳维亚口音，左手食指上有条横贯所有手指的刀疤。
We went to her house, and she asked me to cut up the vegetables. She got out some pans, and lit a cigarette, and made some coffee. She stood really close to me and asked me where I was from and where I was going. She wanted to know everything. And then I was peeling potatoes. She put her arms around my waist, put her head on my shoulder, and smelled my hair and my sweater.
我们去了她家，她让我切蔬菜。她拿出些锅，点了一支烟，煮了些咖啡。她站在离我非常近的地方，问我是从哪里来，要去哪儿。她什么都想知道。然后我在削土豆。她环住我的腰，把头靠在我的肩膀上，闻着我的头发和毛衣。
The first course was potato salad with parsley and vinegar, then sliced tomatoes with grated Parmesan, white wine, then shrimp and salmon with lemon and red wine, and then prime rib with a sweet barbecue sauce, followed by a beaker of cognac. After dinner, she showed me where I could sleep in a bedroom in the attic and said goodnight. But sometime in the middle of the night, she came into my room, naked. I opened my eyes and saw her standing there in the dark.
第一道菜是欧芹醋渍土豆沙拉，然后是磨碎帕玛森干酪的切片番茄，白葡萄酒，然后是柠檬红酒虾和鲑鱼，最后是焦糖烧烤酱肋眼牛排，接着是一烧杯干邑。晚饭后，她告诉我可以在阁楼的卧室睡觉，并说了晚安。但半夜里，她赤身裸体进了我的房间。我睁开眼睛，看到她站在黑暗中。
She got into bed and whispered in German while we made love. Jenkins says, "You made that up." I say, "Maybe some of it."
她上了床，在我们做爱时用德语低语。詹金斯说：“那是你编的。”我说：“也许有一部分是。”
The next day, we leave base camp and walk down to a village at 12,000 feet. We buy canned sardines at the little store and spend the evening drinking its beer, lying on the grass outside, watching the old matron as she bakes bread of us in an adobe oven shaped like a beehive. As it gets dark, the light from the fire coming out the door of the oven is the only light in the village. We lie back, looking at the stars, which in the Andes, are all as bright as planets.
第二天，我们离开大本营，走到海拔12000英尺的一个村庄。我们在小店买罐装沙丁鱼，晚上喝着啤酒躺在草地上，看着老女主人在蜂巢状的土坯烤箱里为我们烤面包。天色暗下来时，烤箱门里透出的炉火光是村里唯一的光。我们躺在那儿看着星星，安第斯山脉的星星像行星一样明亮。
The old woman is standing in front of the oven, staying warm, watching the bread. And my brother walks over and stands next to her. He stands there for a minute and then turns and says,
老妇人站在烤箱前取暖，看着面包。我弟弟走过去站在她身边。他站在那儿一会儿，然后转身说，
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
"Como?" she says. My brother says it again, and again she says, "Como?" "Huesos del condor," he says. "I want to find some condor bones." "No," she shakes her head. "No."
“Como？”她说。我弟弟又说了一遍，她又说了一次“Como？”“Huesos del condor，”他说，“我想找些秃鹰骨头。”“No，”她摇了摇头，“No。”
The hunt begins at dawn, my brother pulling me out of bed onto the floor. "Come on, come on." I'm tying my shoes, and he's out the door. Outside, the fog is lifting off the grass.
狩猎在黎明时分开始，我弟弟把我从床上拽到地板上。“快点，快点。”我正在系鞋带，他已经冲出门外。外面，雾气正从草地上升起。
I'm looking for my brother, but I can't even see the car in the driveway. Then he comes running from the backyard. I run and catch up with him across the street in the Manders' backyard.
我正在找我弟弟，却连车道上的车都看不见。然后他从后院跑了过来。我跑过去在马德尔家后院追上了他。
And he says, "Some animals sleep in the daytime and go out at night to eat. If we hurry, we can catch them before they go back in the ground." I believe him. I have no idea how he knows these things, but he does. He goes out and runs through our neighbor's yards and catches wild animals with his bare hands, mainly lizards, turtles, and snakes. Then he wraps them in his shirt and brings them back to the cages in our room so he can study them.
他说：“有些动物白天睡觉，晚上出来吃东西。如果我们快点，能在它们回地里之前抓住它们。”我相信他。我不知道他怎么知道这些的，但他就是知道。他冲出去，跑过邻居的院子，用双手捕捉野生动物，主要是蜥蜴、乌龟和蛇。然后把它们包在衬衫里带回房间的笼子里以便研究。
I'm running along behind him. And when I lose him in the fog, I follow the tracks he leaves in the dew on the grass. I catch up to him, and he's down on his hands and knees, crawling through the juniper bushes in front of the Gooch's house. He says, "There's a garter snake in here. I saw it. It went right in front of me."
我跟在他后面跑。当我在雾中丢掉他时，我就追踪他留在草地露水上的痕迹。我追上了他，他正趴在地上，爬过古奇家前面的杜松灌木丛。他说：“这儿有条吊带蛇。我看见了。它就在我前面。”
He's crawling around, breaking branches. And I hear the front door open. And there's our neighbor, Daisy Gooch, in her bathrobe.
他在那里爬来爬去，折断树枝。我听到前门开了。邻居黛西·古奇穿着浴袍出来了。
She looks 10 feet tall and 900 years old, and says, "What's going on out here?" I say, "There's a snake in there." She says, "There's no snake in there. You boys get out of here, now." And she starts for us with her broom.
她看起来有10英尺高，900岁了，说：“这儿在干什么？”我说：“这儿有条蛇。”她说：“这儿没蛇。你们快点离开这儿。”然后她拿着扫帚向我们冲来。
We take off running. We don't need to run that far. It's not like she's going to come after us. But we keep running anyway. We jump the fence at Gerholt's house, and we're on the golf course, heading towards the gully.
我们掉头就跑。我们不需要跑那么远。她又不会真追过来。但我们还是不停地跑。我们跳过格霍尔特家的围栏，上了高尔夫球场，朝着沟壑跑去。
My brother says, "I think I figured out a way to run and not get tired. It's all in how you breathe. Yesterday, I ran over to the gully and down to the river and back, and I didn't get out of breath. I can run as far as I want." "Like the Indians," I say. "Yeah, like the Indians."
我弟弟说：“我想出一个跑步不累的方法。全在于怎么呼吸。昨天，我跑过沟壑到河边再跑回来，一点也没喘。我想跑多远就跑多远。”“像印第安人那样，”我说。“是的，像印第安人那样。”
My brother and I are of a savage mind, running down the fourth fairway. Never has the golf course been hunted by two so brave. We have everything we need. The wilderness is unfolding in front of us.
我弟弟和我怀着野蛮的心，跑过第四球道。高尔夫球场从未被如此勇敢的两人狩猎过。我们有需要的一切。荒野在我们面前展开。
Scott Carrier lives in Salt Lake City. Musical interludes during that story by Jenny Magnus here in Chicago. Coming up, loving animals, really loving them. And loving somebody who your family hates. That's in a minute when our program continues.
斯科特·卡里尔住在盐湖城。故事中的音乐插曲由芝加哥的珍妮·马格努斯提供。接下来，爱动物，真正地爱它们。以及爱一个你家人讨厌的人。节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers, reporters, and documentary producers to do a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. But this week, for a change, we're playing some of the stories that we have found or commissioned and have not been able to figure out a way to work into some theme. Or sometimes shows got so crowded, because we got so much material we liked, we squeezed it out and said, "Well, we'll run this sometime."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、表演者、记者和纪录片制作人来做各种关于该主题的故事。但这周，为了改变一下，我们播放一些我们发现或委托创作，但一直没想出办法融入任何主题的故事。或者有时候节目太拥挤了，因为我们有太多喜欢的素材，我们就把它们挤出去说：“好吧，我们改天再播。”
The future has arrived. It is sometime. In short, it is our fall clearance sale, where we are clearing the inventory off the shelves and passing the big radio values on to you. That's right, you.
未来已来。就是现在。简而言之，这是我们的秋季清理大甩卖，我们要把货架上的库存清空，把巨大的广播价值带给你们。没错，就是你。
Before we go any further, some of you may recall a few weeks ago, we played you some of the work of Greg Whitehead, of the Institute for Scream Studies. Whitehead is gathering the sound of people screaming, stories about people screaming, thoughts about the meaning of various screams. It is his belief that screams, that we take them as a unit, that we take all screams as being the same, that screams have more meaning than we generally understand.
在继续之前，有些人可能还记得几周前，我们给你们播放了尖叫研究研究所格雷格·怀特黑德的一些作品。怀特黑德正在收集人们尖叫的声音、关于人们尖叫的故事、关于各种尖叫意义的思考。他认为尖叫不仅仅是一个单位，我们认为所有尖叫都是一样的，尖叫比我们通常理解的具有更多的意义。
And he's gathering these from around the world. And we invited you to contribute to his research by calling a special phone number and leaving your thoughts and screams. And so far, many of you have responded.
他正在世界各地收集这些。我们邀请你们拨打专门的电话号码，留下你们的感想和尖叫，以此来参与他的研究。到目前为止，你们很多人都作出了回应。
Hi, my name is Oliver, and I'm going to leave my scream.
你好，我叫奥利弗，我要留下我的尖叫。
[SCREAM]
[尖叫声]
Hi. I'm the lead singer in a band called Hate Wave and the lyrics are all screaming. So I'll give you the first verse from a song called [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Ghosts.
你好。我是“仇恨波”乐队的主唱，歌词全是尖叫。所以我给你们唱一首叫《[不清晰]鬼魂》的歌的第一段。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
For eight-plus years, I have been unable to express an emotion so devastating. When I learned about this scream line, I felt it may be an opportunity to free my spirit from the bondage of the trauma that catapulted me into the void of insanity. Someone said, "I think you hit something. I think you hit a kid." This is impossible, because I saw no one. I stopped the bus, all the while knowing that in order to hit anything, something had to be there."
八年多了，我一直无法表达一种如此毁灭性的情绪。当我得知这个尖叫热线时，我觉得这可能是一个机会，可以把我的灵魂从那场把我弹射进疯狂虚无的创伤束缚中解放出来。有人说：“我想你撞到了什么。我想你撞到了个孩子。”这不可能，因为我谁也没看见。我停下了车，但一直知道要撞到什么，必然有东西在那儿。
If you have not called our line yet, we urge you to call the line. The number is 312-832-3326. And we want screams, thoughts about screams, stories about screams. Don't put this off. Do it today or tomorrow. If Greg Whitehead gets enough of these, he'll put together another full story in a future edition of our program. Again, the number, 312-832-3326, a little radio experiment.
如果你还没拨打过我们的热线，我们敦促你拨打。号码是312-832-3326。我们想要尖叫、关于尖叫的思考、关于尖叫的故事。别推迟了。今天或明天就做。如果格雷格·怀特黑德收到了足够多的这些，他会在我们未来节目的版本中整理出另一个完整的故事。再说一遍，号码是312-832-3326，一个小小的广播实验。
And while we have the lab coats on, we might as well move on to act three, Everyday Anthropology. This is a posting from a Usenet group on the internet. It's one of these places where people post messages to each other. And this is from, I believe, the zoophilia group. And one of the things I should make a distinction about right up front is-- well, even before we make that distinction, let me just say right up front, some of this material might not be suitable for some of our younger listeners. Again, use your discretion.
趁着我们还穿着实验服，不如继续第三幕，《日常人类学》。这是互联网上一个Usenet新闻组的帖子。这是人们互发信息的地方之一。我想，这是来自兽恋群组。我首先要做出一个区分——嗯，甚至在做出那个区分之前，我先声明，有些材料可能不适合我们的一些年轻听众。再次强调，请自行斟酌。
All right, now on to the subject at hand. Apparently, there's a difference between zoophilia and bestiality. If that doesn't make scared parents turn off their radios, I don't know what will.
好了，现在谈谈手头的话题。显然，兽恋和兽奸之间是有区别的。如果这不能让受惊的父母关掉收音机，那我就不知道什么能了。
There's a difference. Apparently, people who are into bestiality want to-- how to say this-- want to physically love an animal. And people who are into zoophilia actually fall in love. They actually fall in love with the animal. Anyway, somebody posted this to one of these groups.
是有区别的。显然，沉迷于兽奸的人想要——怎么说呢——想要在身体上爱动物。而沉迷于兽恋的人是真的坠入爱河。他们是真的爱上了动物。总之，有人把这个发到了这些群组之一。
"The first time I ever heard of bestiality was in 12th grade. My future husband told me that he had sexual fantasies involving animals. At the time, I was intrigued. My curiosity was piqued. I wrote in my journal, 'I want to know what he wants to do, and with what species.' That was all the thought I ever gave it. I knew that fantasies were just that, fantasies, in which anything could happen.
“我第一次听说兽奸是在12年级。我未来的丈夫告诉我，他有涉及动物的性幻想。当时，我很好奇。好奇心被激起了。我在日记里写道：‘我想知道他想做什么，用什么物种。’那是我对他所有的思考。我知道幻想就是幻想，在其中任何事情都可能发生。
Over the next several years, as we attended university, moved in together, eventually got married, he spoke frequently about animals, particularly horses, which he had always loved. I did not find this strange, his love, as I love cats. I know people who are dog-crazy or whatever.
在接下来的几年里，当我们上大学、住在一起、最终结婚时，他经常谈论动物，特别是马，他一直很喜欢马。我不觉得这种爱很奇怪，就像我爱猫一样。我知道有些人是狗痴或者别的什么。
The sexual aspect never once occurred to me, despite what he had told me in high school. He loved to look at pictures of them, would practically run us off the road to stare at a 'horsey,' in quotes, loved watching nature shows, particularly the ones that showed real matings between almost any sort of animal. I didn't find this odd, as I am a bit prurient myself, sometimes."
性方面的因素一次也没有出现在我的脑海里，尽管他在高中时就告诉过我。他喜欢看动物的照片，几乎会把我们带到路边盯着一匹‘马’，带引号的，喜欢看自然节目，特别是那些展示几乎任何物种间真实交配的节目。我没觉得这很奇怪，因为有时候我自己也有点色情。”
This thing goes on. It's really this very odd human document, both of her denial and of what happens. "As we grew closer, he revealed other dreams and fantasies he had. Some, like the dream of us being lions and mating together, were wonderful turn-ons for me. I don't judge people's dreams. They can't control what their mind does when they're asleep. Others, like a fantasy of us being horses, struck me as odd, but not totally insane. Even the fact that he wanted to have sex with me on horseback didn't seem too strange to me. Impractical, uncomfortable, yes. Strange, no.
这东西还在继续。这真的是一份非常奇怪的人类文档，既有她的否认，也有后续发生的事情。“随着我们关系更加亲密，他透露了其他梦想和幻想。有些，像我们变成狮子一起交配的梦，对我来说是非常美妙的刺激。我不评判别人的梦想。当他们睡着时，他们无法控制大脑做什么。其他的，像我们变成马的幻想，让我觉得很奇怪，但并不完全疯狂。甚至他想在马背上和我做爱的事实对我来说也没觉得太奇怪。不切实际、不舒服，是的。奇怪，不。”
He asked me if I thought having sex with an animal would constitute adultery. This should've clued me in, but perhaps I was blind to something that was so out of the question. I thought what most people think, that only desperate people would ever have to resort to an animal. I figured horny teenagers with no other outlet, or really gruesome-looking adults.
他问我，认为和动物做爱是否构成通奸。这本该给我点提示，但也许我对自己认为是完全不可能的事情视而不见。我想的是大多数人所想的，只有绝望的人才会不得不求助于动物。我以为是没处发泄的发情青少年，或者长相非常恐怖的成年人。
I could not figure out why he was asking. He just said he was curious. We have hypothetical conversations like that from time to time, so I did not think this was anything special.
我不明白他为什么要问。他只是说他好奇。我们时不时会有那种假设性的谈话，所以我没觉得这有什么特别。
I never thought it was odd that he would spend hours just visiting friends who own horses, or going to the race track just to look at them, or going to the races but never betting, or biking for miles just to go to a farm on the far side of the bay. When he said he couldn't sleep at night--" Hold on. I'm going to queue up some more music here. Let's see about this music right here. You guys hear that? We're having a technical problem here with our music. All right, go to this music again.
我从不觉得他花几小时去探望拥有马的朋友、或者去赛马场只为看它们一眼、或者去赛马但从不下注、或者骑车好几英里去海湾对岸的农场很奇怪。当他说他晚上睡不着时——等一下。我要再排点音乐。看看这个音乐。你们听到了吗？我们的音乐出技术问题了。好吧，再放这个音乐。
"When he said he couldn't sleep at night and would go for walks until 2:00 in the morning, I worried about him, but never once thought he was going to fence-hop at the track and make a stallion his new boyfriend. I just though he was worried about school or work or us."
“当他说他晚上睡不着，会散步到凌晨2点时，我很为他担心，但从没想过他会翻过围栏在赛道上让一匹种马做他的新男友。我只是以为他担心学校或工作，或者我们。”
Anyway, then she talks about how they got an internet connection. And he starts signing onto these groups where they discuss this stuff on the net. And she says, "I didn't care in the least what he read, but he started getting very paranoid every time I walked by the computer. He'd stay up late at night, downloading pictures I never got to see, reading stories I never got to read.
总之，然后她谈到了他们怎么连接了互联网。他开始登录这些群组，在网上讨论这些东西。她说：“我一点也不关心他读什么，但他开始变得非常偏执，每次我走过电脑旁。他会熬夜，下载我从没看过的照片，阅读我从没读过的故事。”
We began snapping at each other. I was angry that he was always on the net, ignoring me. He was angry because I wouldn't give him any, quote, 'privacy.'"
我们开始互相吵架。我很生气他总是上网，忽略我。他很生气因为我不给他所谓的‘隐私’。”
Anyway, it goes on and on. And finally he tells her. She confronts him. She says, "Don't hide this from me." "And then he said the sentence that changed our lives," she wrote.
总之，事情没完没了。最后他告诉了她。她质问他。她说：“别瞒着我。”“然后他说了改变我们生活的那句话，”她写道。
"'I mean, I haven't done half of what some of those people have done.' 'Done?' I asked. 'Oh my god. Open mouth, insert foot.' He laughed at himself, then hung his head, looking totally lost and defeated. 'I didn't mean to tell you that yet.' He started to cry.
“‘我的意思是，我还没做过那些人做过的一半事情。’‘做过？’我问。‘天哪。祸从口出。’他自嘲地笑了笑，然后低下了头，看起来完全迷茫和挫败。‘我还没打算告诉你这个。’他开始哭。”
My thoughts came flooding, all mostly gibberish. No wonder I have to convince him to make love. Doesn't he love me? Why? Why? Why?"
我的思绪涌了上来，几乎全是胡言乱语。难怪我必须劝他做爱。他不爱我吗？为什么？为什么？为什么？
Then she goes on explaining about zoophilia and all she's learned, and how she tried to comfort him. And then she says, in a way, people who go through other experiences have these kinds of things. She said, "I wanted to cry. I felt so close to him because of what he told me. I felt I finally knew him."
然后她继续解释兽恋以及她所学到的一切，以及她如何试图安慰他。然后她说，在某种程度上，经历其他经验的人也会有这类事情。她说：“我想哭。因为他告诉我的事，我觉得和他如此亲近。我觉得我终于了解他了。”
She says that she wrote him a letter. Anyway, she goes on to say how she's come to peace with it by talking about other people, by talking to other people who have these desires. She says, "It took me a while to realize there was so much diversity in the world. I am very glad I had the opportunity to find out. I've also abandoned the idea that he breaks his wedding vows every time he's with an animal. It's not as if he would ever leave me for a horse.
她说她写了一封信给他。总之，她接着说她是如何通过谈论其他人、通过与有这些欲望的人交谈来达成平和的。她说：“我花了一段时间才意识到世界上有这么多多样性。我很高兴有机会发现这一点。我也放弃了他每次和动物在一起就违反结婚誓言的想法。并不是说他会为了马离开我。
He's told me that what he feels for the horse is totally different from what he feels for me. The horse fills a kind of spiritual void that I cannot. While I am saddened by the fact that I cannot fulfill all of his needs, in fact, I don't fulfill all his needs, I've come to realize with the help of our zoophile friends that there is no way for anyone to be all things to him, or to anyone. I obviously don't have the right equipment to be a stallion for him. Grin," it says.
他告诉我，他对马的感觉和他对我的感觉完全不同。马填补了我无法填补的一种精神空白。虽然我因为不能满足他的所有需求而感到难过，事实上，我确实没能满足他的所有需求，但在我们的兽恋朋友的帮助下，我意识到任何人都不可能成为他的全部，或者说成为任何人的全部。显然我没有成为他的种马所需的设备。笑，”上面写着。
"His coming out actually made our marriage better, since all the pain we've struggled through brought us closer. Even hearing what he had done with the animals made me feel closer to him, since it revealed a part of him I didn't know existed. He has told me that if I forced him to choose, he would pick me in an instant. I hope I never get that petty, petty enough to force him into a choice like that."
“他的出柜实际上改善了我们的婚姻，因为我们经历的所有痛苦让我们更加亲密。甚至听到他与动物所做的事情也让我觉得和他更亲近，因为它揭示了他一部分我不知道存在的方面。他告诉我，如果我强迫他选择，他会立刻选择我。希望我永远不会变得那么卑微，卑微到强迫他做那样的选择。”
Act Four.
第四幕。
When I was a little girl, I thought my grandmother, [? Tuesie, ?] was an angel. I really did. My mother, Bonnie, was what she called a career girl. And after she and my father separated, I was left with my grandparents for the first five years of my childhood.
当我还是个小女孩时，我认为我的祖母图西是个天使。我真的这么认为。我母亲邦妮是她所说的职业女性。在我父母分居后，我前五年的童年是在祖父母家度过的。
Carmen Delzell stumbled into this next story after a funeral. And to get the story, I think you really have to understand the funeral. Carmen is from Texas. And the person who she was closest with as a child was her grandmother, who she adored, and who adored her. And the grandma's house was always orderly and clean, versus the chaos of Carmen's parents' houses.
卡门·德尔泽尔在一次葬礼后偶然发现了接下来的这个故事。为了理解这个故事，我想你真的得理解那场葬礼。卡门来自德克萨斯州。小时候她最亲近的人是她的祖母，她崇拜她，祖母也崇拜她。和卡门父母家混乱的环境相比，祖母家总是整洁有序。
A few years ago, Carmen put together a little documentary about her grandma, [? Tuesie ?], who was then in a nursing home and not too happy about it. And in that documentary, she talked with her grandmother about heaven, about the past. And she remembered what it was like growing up with a Bible Belt, Christian grandma.
几年前，卡门制作了一部关于她祖母图西的小纪录片，那时她住在疗养院里，对现状不太满意。在那部纪录片里，她和祖母谈论天堂，谈论过去。她记起了和一位基督教祖母一起长大的感觉。
Sundays were always a problem for me. When I was little and living with her, I grew to dread the long, boring services, and the way all the ladies greeted me and asked me if I'd been baptized and washed in the blood of the Lamb. As I grew older, I pretended to be sick, so I could stay home and read the funny papers, even though the grandmother said the devil was laughing at me when I ignored the church bells that rang from six blocks away. And of course, the civil rights issues of the '60s suddenly made me aware that there were no black people in our church, even though we had to drive through a poor, black neighborhood to get there. [? Tuesie ?] brushed away my questions by telling me colored folks had their own way of worship, and that they wouldn't enjoy the quiet Park Place Baptist services.
“星期天对我来说总是麻烦。当我小时候住在那儿时，我开始害怕漫长、枯燥的礼拜，害怕那些女士问我是否受过洗礼、是否在羔羊的血中洗净。当我长大些时，我装病留在家里看搞笑报纸，尽管祖母说当我无视六个街区外响起的教堂钟声时，魔鬼正在嘲笑我。当然，60年代的民权问题突然让我意识到我们的教堂里没有黑人，尽管我们必须开车穿过一个贫穷的黑人社区才能到达那儿。图西通过告诉我黑人有自己的礼拜方式，而且他们不会喜欢安静的公园广场浸信会礼拜，来打发我的疑问。”
[MUSIC PLAYING - "SWING LOW, SWEET CHARIOT]
[音乐播放 - “低低摇摆吧，甜蜜的战车”]
Can you hear that?
你能听到吗？
Yes.
能。
Can you hear what they're singing?
你能听到他们在唱什么吗？
Oh, yes.
噢，是的。
What are they singing?
他们在唱什么？
Swing low, sweet chariot, coming to carry me home.
低低摇摆吧，甜蜜的战车，来载我回家。
Do you like it, or do you not like it that much?
你喜欢它，还是不太喜欢它？
No, I never have liked that song.
不，我从来没喜欢过那首歌。
Why?
为什么？
Well, I always thought it was just a bunch of black people having a picnic or something.
嗯，我一直以为那只是一群黑人在野餐什么的。
Damn, hell, and god, were words that could never be used in my grandparents' house, never. "Nigger," though, that was a word nobody seemed to mind. The damn niggers were getting too big for their britches. They were getting sassy. And worst of all, they wanted to sit next to you on the bus and at the Woolworth's lunch counter.
“该死、见鬼、上帝”，是在我祖父母家绝对不能用的词，绝对不能。不过，“黑鬼”这个词，没人介意。该死的黑鬼越来越狂妄了。他们变得没大没小。最糟糕的是，他们想在公共汽车上和伍尔沃斯午餐柜台旁坐在你身边。
I heard this kind of talk my whole life from my grandmother, but it didn't begin to sink in until we couldn't go to Ocean View Amusement Park any more, because they said niggers went there. Meanwhile, my father, who thought [? Tuesie ?] was crazy as a bedbug and I was just like her, was running for school board on a platform of integration of the Beaumont, Texas, school system. He and my mother joined the Unitarian church, which, according to my grandmother, were a bunch of heathens. And the tension between my two families became more apparent and terribly confusing for me.
我一生中从祖母那里听过这种谈话，但直到我们不能再去海洋景观游乐园，因为据说黑鬼去那儿，我才开始意识到这一点。与此同时，认为图西像床虫一样疯狂而我像她的父亲，正在以博蒙特学区整合为纲领竞选教育委员会成员。他和母亲加入了唯一神教派教堂，据我祖母说，那是一群异教徒。我和两个家庭之间的紧张关系变得更加明显，让我感到极度困惑。
OK, well that is the story that you need to know before we could bring you this latest installment from Carmen's life. Carmen's now back in Texas. And she put this story together with radio producer Jay Allison.
好了，这就是在把卡门生活的最新片段带给你之前，你需要知道的故事。卡门现在回到了德克萨斯州。她和广播制作人杰·艾利森一起制作了这个故事。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "PINK PANTHER THEME" BY EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆演奏的“粉红豹主题”]
I play anything. If I wanted to sit here and play "Batman."
我什么都玩。如果我想坐在这里演奏“蝙蝠侠”。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "BATMAN THEME" BY EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆演奏的“蝙蝠侠主题”]
If I wanted to sit here and play "Green Acres."
如果我想坐在这里演奏“绿色土地”。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "GREEN ACRES THEME" BY EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆演奏的“绿色土地主题”]
You name it. If I wanted to sit here and play "The Beverly Hillbillies."
你随便点。如果我想坐在这里演奏“贝弗利山人”。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "THE BEVERLY HILLBILLIES THEME" BY EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆演奏的“贝弗利山人主题”]
Anything. If I wanted to play "Gilligan's Island."
随便什么。如果我想演奏“吉利根岛”。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "GILLIGAN'S ISLAND THEME" BY EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆演奏的“吉利根岛主题”]
You just name it. I just play a variety of music.
你随便点。我就演奏各种音乐。
That's EZ Malone from Currituck, North Carolina. My daughter and I were lucky enough to meet him in a junk store on our way home from my grandmother's funeral. EZ was looking for an electric frying pan. We weren't looking for anything in particular, until he looked at us and said "Hah." And that's when I realized we'd been looking for him.
那是来自北卡罗来纳州科里塔克的埃兹·马隆。我和女儿很幸运，在从祖母葬礼回家的路上在一家旧货店遇到了他。埃兹在找电煎锅。我们没什么特别要找的，直到他看着我们说“哈”。就在那时我意识到我们一直在找他。
He said he'd been homeless a few years ago in New York City, until he met his girlfriend, Phyllis. She got him to move back to North Carolina, and they brought along her brain-damaged sister, who laughs all the time. And they all live together in a rented trailer. It's not so clear how they make a living. Sometimes, EZ gets a gig at a place called Fishbone's, down the road in a town called Duck.
他说他几年前在纽约市无家可归，直到遇到了女朋友菲利斯。她让他搬回北卡罗来纳，他们还带上了她那个总是笑个不停、脑损伤的妹妹。他们全都住在一辆出租拖车里。他们怎么维持生计不太清楚。有时候，埃兹会在鸭镇路边的鱼骨餐馆找到演出机会。
He told us he could play the guitar his teeth and his feet. But it was the way he talked that convinced us to invite him to my son's place for supper. We never could have done if my grandmother was in the car. She was afraid of black men. But since she was dead, I figured it was OK.
他告诉我们他能用牙齿和脚弹吉他。但正是他说话的方式让我们决定邀请他到我儿子家吃晚饭。如果我祖母在车里，我们绝不可能这样做。她害怕黑人。但既然她去世了，我想应该没问题。
Now I'll tell you, it all started in church, when I used to go to church with my father years ago. He was a minister, by the way. So when I was just a lad, my father told me, he said, "I'm going to buy you a guitar." And being so young, I took it for a joke. Time passed, and he actually bought me a guitar. So there I was, late at night, all times of night, just bamming on the guitar. I wasn't making no sense with the thing, just--
现在我告诉你，这一切都始于教堂，多年前我常和父亲去教堂。顺便说一下，他是位牧师。当我还是个孩子时，父亲告诉我，他说：“我要给你买把吉他。”我当时太小，以为他在开玩笑。时间流逝，他真的给我买了一把吉他。于是我深夜，整晚都在拨弄吉他。我根本搞不懂那玩意儿，只是——
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
--beating and bamming on it. Wasn't getting nothing out of it. And I said to him, I said, I wants to get so I can help you out. And I'm going to learn this thing through the help of the Lord. So there I was, upstairs in the room, just bamming on the guitar, trying to learn, day and night.
——敲打着它。什么也没弹出来。我对他说，我说，我希望能帮上你的忙。我要在上帝的帮助下学会这个东西。所以我整天整夜在楼上的房间里拨弄吉他，试图学习。
And he encouraged me when he told me. He said, "When you learn how to play just three chords," sort of thing, "I'm going to take you to church and let you play," because I love going to church even now.
当他告诉我时他鼓励我。他说：“当你学会怎么只弹三个和弦时，”那种事，“我要带你去教堂，让你弹，”因为直到现在我都爱去教堂。
So there I was in my bedroom, alone, sitting on my bed. And I was just a child. And I told Jesus. I said, "Lord," I said, "I want to play this thing to help my daddy out, because he's preaching your word. And he needs somebody to go with him." And all of a sudden out of nowhere, the Lord spoke to me in a solid voice from the inside. And he showed me this chord here, the E chord.
所以在那儿，我独自在卧室里，坐在床上。我还是个孩子。我告诉耶稣。我说，“主啊，”我说，“我想弹这东西帮我爸爸，因为他在传你的道。他需要人陪他。”突然间，没有任何预兆，主以一种坚定的声音从里面跟我说话。他向我展示了这个和弦，E和弦。
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
The Lord showed me. Never been to school for it. And I went downstairs, and I ran down there and showed it to my daddy. I said, "Dad, I believe I'm ready to play in church." And he'd say, "Well, let me hear what you sound like." And I didn't have but that one chord.
主展示给我看了。我从未上过学。我跑下楼，跑到那儿向我爸爸展示。我说：“爸爸，我相信我准备好在教堂演奏了。”他说：“好吧，让我听听你弹得怎么样。”我只会那一个和弦。
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
And he said, "Well, get two more chords, and I will take you to church. Learn two more notes, And I will take you to church." Oh, that excited me. So I ran back upstairs in my bedroom. And I told God, I said, "Lord, I need two more chords, just two more chords." And the Lord showed me the A.
他说：“好吧，再学两个和弦，我就带你去教堂。再学两个音符，我就带你去教堂。”哦，那让我太兴奋了。于是我跑回楼上的卧室。我告诉上帝，我说：“主啊，我需要两个和弦，再要两个就行了。”主向我展示了A和弦。
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
Then he showed me the B.
然后他展示了B和弦。
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
Then I had three chords. And I rushed downstairs. I could not get down there fast enough and show him the three chords I'd learned. I ran up to him. I said, "Dad, listen to his."
然后我有了三个和弦。我冲下楼。我迫不及待地想向他展示我学会的三个和弦。我跑到他面前。我说：“爸爸，听听这个。”
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
He said, "That's good. Show me another one." I said--
他说：“那很好。再展示一个给我看。”我说——
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
He said, "That's good." He said, "Do you got one more?" I said--
他说：“那很好。”他说：“你还有吗？”我说——
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
So I went on like that there. And he took me to church and got me in front of a crowd of people. And it was so crowded in there, and I was so nervous, I couldn't hardly hold my legs still from shaking. And he said to the church, he said, "My son is going to make the guitar say 'Jesus.'"
就这样我一直弹下去。他带我去教堂，把我带到一群人面前。里面人头攒动，我太紧张了，腿都在抖，根本停不下来。他对教堂的人说：“我儿子要让吉他叫出‘耶稣’。”
Now I looked at my mother. And I said, "Excuse me, mama. I need to talk to you." And she said, "What is it?" I said, "Well, now, which son is he talking about?" She said, "Son, you know he's talking about you."
我看着母亲。我说：“对不起，妈。我得跟你说句话。”她说：“什么事？”我说：“嗯，现在，他说的是哪个儿子？”她说：“儿子，你知道他说的是你。”
I said, "Well, I can't make no guitar call 'Jesus,' you know?" She said, "Well, you know your dad don't play. So when you actually do it, you better learn something."
我说：“嗯，我可没法让吉他叫‘耶稣’，你知道吧？”她说：“嗯，你知道你爸不会弹。所以当你真的做的时候，你最好学点什么。”
Get out there and hit the guitar, he hollared off. And like I said, being a minister, he would sing a song before he'd preach. And he said, "My son is going to make the guitar say Jesus." He said, "When I say 'Jesus," my son is going to make the guitar say 'Jesus.'" So he hauled off and looked at me. And he said, "Jesus." And I said--
他大喊着让我出去弹吉他。就像我说的，作为牧师，他会在布道前唱首歌。他说：“我儿子要让吉他叫出耶稣。”他说：“当我喊‘耶稣’时，我儿子就要让吉他叫出‘耶稣’。”于是他站好看着我。他说：“耶稣。”我就说——
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
And he stooped down before me and said, "Excuse me. You want me to take that guitar from you?" I said, "No, sir." He said, "I'm going to say it again. If you don't make it say Jesus, I'm going to take it from you." So he hollered off, man. He's scary, I'm telling you. And he said, "Jesus." And I said--
他俯下身对我说：“对不起。你想让我把吉他收走吗？”我说：“不，先生。”他说：“我要再喊一次。如果你不让它叫耶稣，我就把它收走。”于是他大喊，天哪。他很吓人，我告诉你。他说：“耶稣。”我就说——
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
He said, "Excuse me, church," and leaned down to me like this. "You want me to whip your tail?" I said, "No, sir. I don't want you to whip me tail. Please don't whip me. Please." Because when my father says he will whip you, he  will whip you.
他说：“对不起，教堂，”然后这样俯身对我说。“你想让我鞭打你的尾巴（屁股）吗？”我说：“不，先生。我不想让你鞭打我。求求你别鞭打我。求你了。”因为当父亲说他会鞭打你时，他真的会鞭打你。
So I said, "Say it one more time. And I'm going to try to get it out this time." And he said it the third time. And when he said "Jesus," it came out of nowhere.
所以我说：“再说一次。我这次会尽力做到的。”他说第三次。当他喊出“耶稣”时，它从虚无中蹦了出来。
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
Like that there. And then he said, "I believe he can do a little bit better than that." I said, "No, I can't. I don't even know how I've done that," right? So he hollered off again. He said, "Jesus." And the next thing I remember,
像那样。然后他说：“我相信他可以做得再好点。”我说：“不，我不行。我甚至不知道自己是怎么做到的，”对吧？于是他又大喊。他说：“耶稣。”接下来我记得的是，
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
And that's how I learned to play. I learned through the miracle of Jesus Christ, and I learned through the fear for my father.
我就是这样学会弹奏的。我是通过耶稣基督的奇迹学会的，我是通过对父亲的恐惧学会的。
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
EZ played the guitar with my son for the rest of the night while the women talked and laughed in the kitchen. I couldn't help wondering if my grandmother had heard EZ's story. It's funny how Jesus was so important to both of them. But she always told me when I was little that there were two heavens, one for black people and one for white. I don't think so.
埃兹那天晚上剩下的时间一直和我儿子弹吉他，女人们在厨房里谈笑风生。我不禁好奇祖母有没有听到埃兹的故事。有趣的是，耶稣对他们俩都那么重要。但她小时候常告诉我，天堂有两个，一个是给黑人的，一个是给白人的。我不这么认为。
[MUSIC PLAYING - EZ MALONE]
[音乐播放 - 埃兹·马隆]
Carmen Delzell's story was produced by Jay Allison. It comes from Jay's ongoing series, Life Stories, which is produced with consulting producer Christina Egloff with funds from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting and the National Endowment for the Arts.
卡门·德尔泽尔的故事由杰·艾利森制作。它来自杰的系列节目《生活故事》，该系列由咨询制作人克里斯蒂娜·埃格洛夫制作，并获得公共广播公司和国家艺术基金会的资助。
Our program was produced today by Alix Speigel and myself with Peter Clowney and Nancy Updike, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin.
今天的节目由阿里克斯·斯皮格尔和我自己制作，彼得·克劳尼和南希·厄普代克参与，特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
If you want a copy of this program, it costs $10. Call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380.
如果你想要本节目的拷贝，费用是10美元。请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，312-832-3380。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
WBEZ管理监督托雷·马拉蒂亚。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。